before we get to the mailbag i do have
to get to one story
we've been talking about how we
shouldn't forget things for much of the
show
i'd like to give one example at least
where it might be worth forgetting
things where we're remembering a little
bit too much this is the downside of big
tech and cancel culture
there's a woman maddie ziegler i had no
idea who this person was until i read
this news story
maddie ziegler is a dancer and an
actress she is
currently 17 years old and she's
issued a public apology for offensive
comments
and jokes that she made in the past
how far in the past could that be she's
17 years old what kind of public apology
i was thinking in my head i thought
what is she going to do she's going to
apologize for comments she made when she
was nine
yes that's what she's doing she is a 17
year old girl
is now being pressured by the left to
make a public apology
for comments she made when i kid you not
she was nine years old
because she made some videos where i
don't know she made fun of an
asian or a chinese accent or something
like that
like you know kids do you know how kids
do that stuff kids say silly things
and do silly things because they're kids
that's what kids it's like the
definition of kids
well she has to make this public apology
it does raise questions why would you
want your nine-year-old kid
to be on camera on the internet that
seems like a bad idea that seems like a
recipe for disaster
just generally you don't want to expose
kids to that very young
but but beyond that
can we not have a little bit of grace
for the things that nine-year-olds say i
mean i guess what the age of reason is
seven
but let's see you know nine is still
pretty far below the age of consent i
think in in
many states 17 is still below the age of
consent so can we
not have a little bit of grace for that
no of course not
of course we can't not in this culture
because no one really cares what a
nine-year-old girl
said about some chinese accent who said
no no one cares
but they want to use it as a cudgel now
to intimidate people
to whip them back in line history is
used by the left
selectively like blackmail like any
like any extortion artist like any
blackmailer like any thug
uses against his adversaries
that's that's not how history should be
used we should not approach history
as a as a tool of exploitation and we
should not exploit history
from a perspective of antagonism
we should approach history for what it
is it's things that happened in the past
that might tell us something about the
future
we should look at history as something
that is complex we should look at
history
as something that can give us a guide to
the future and if someone has for
instance a 50-year
career in politics that is highly
undignified and is increasingly radical
we should remember that too and that
should play a role in a presidential
campaign
but we must approach in its complexity i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you